con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar del humor y la religión y
para ello saludamos en este momento a
Julio César González el matador
caricaturista colombiano Julio César
Gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de viernes en directo América de
France 24 obviamente temas espinosos
humor religión Quiero preguntarle
primeramente si hay límites no para esto
Hola Raúl muy buenos días
un saludo a toda la gente de Franz 24 y
a la gente que nos ve Bueno yo creo que
que el humor es es algo
importantísimo en el ser humano y en el
vivir más que en el vivir en el convivir
creería yo
Cuál es la la función del humor en
nuestra sociedad no que específicamente
catarsis podemos hacer nosotros para
poder pues leer el humor para eso no
como como se hace como crítica social
crítica política
Raúl yo creo que lo fundamental del
humor es yo creo que sacarnos de la
locura una persona que ríe es una
persona que tiene yo creería que tiene
un buen sentido de autocrítica no es no
es no es raro encontrar en en regímenes
totalitarios o
que la gente no se sepa reír o no se
pueda reír
hay también un caso muy importante pues
me imagino que conoce la publicación
francesa charlievdo donde han sido
digamos muy críticos en estas
caricaturas contra el islamismo no sobre
todo el profeta Mahoma en estos últimos
días evidentemente ahí está exactamente
y en los últimos días también en con
todo lo que tiene que ver pues con las
protestas en Irán que han ido más fuerte
a esto se cumplieron ya también ocho
años del ataque a Charlie do se puede
trabajar con libertad cuando se
deshumorista Cuando se es grecaturista
hablo de libertad sin miedos no sin
miedo a a una represalia por un ataque
religioso no
bueno es que realmente el el solo hecho
de decir la verdad a través de
caricaturas terminó convertido en una
profesión de riesgo en mi país yo en ese
momento cuento con con protección del
Estado porque más que temas religiosos
lo que se defienden Son son posiciones
políticas si ustedes ven hacerle una
caricatura a un talibán es pena de
muerte
Entonces por qué Porque la caricatura a
través del humor dice la verdad Entonces
a los que están en el poder no les
conviene no les gusta el humor porque el
humor es el humor transgrede y es el
muestra
desenmascaro el simulacro que es el
poder como tal en muchas ocasiones Julio
hablamos del humor político hasta este
momento no pero el humor pudiera ser
digamos ofensivo en otros aspectos
cuando un humorista haciendo estando
como y se mete con un cierto tipo de
población o algo no y estamos también en
un momento de la vida y en un momento de
la sociedad en el mundo donde todo puede
ser y es catalogado como ofensivo para
todas las personas Qué opinión le merece
esto
yo creo que estamos entrando al terreno
de lo políticamente correcto es que el
sentido del humor es un sentido
transgresor y la pregunta es
nos podemos de reír de todo sí o no yo
pensaría que sí porque eso es liberador
le hoy en día de las sociedades tienden
a que cualquier tipo de humor ofende a
alguien y es que realmente el la
carcajada ofende a alguien el buen humor
sacan pollas y levanta y levanta
situaciones que
que no le gustan a la gente a ciertos
sectores pero pero ojo Raúl
la sociedad está es Es más delicada en
este sentido y
estamos terminando en la tiranía de las
minorías hay una hay un hay un hay un
estándar come de David
[Música]
en televisión que es buenísimo
y trata temas que la gente no quisiera
que se tratase Julio lo peligroso lo
peligroso Perdón interrumpo de caer en
lo que usted llama lo políticamente
correcto no y Y censurar de alguna
manera Pues el humor crítico y el humor
bueno como también lo estaba diciendo
usted A qué se refiere también como
humor bueno
bueno es que hay formas hay formas de
abordar el humor soy un humor que puede
llegar incluso a ser bizarro que es un
que es un humor muy ofensivo Pero no por
eso no debe no debemos censurarlo Habrá
gente que le gusta ese tipo de
contenidos Habrá gente que no no tenemos
que matar al caricaturista que hace ese
tipo de caricatura es lo mismo la gente
que hace grafitis que que hace
intervenciones artísticas
Con un fuerte Con un fuerte sentido del
humor incluso ofensivo pero la no por
eso debemos batarlo y acallarlo porque
ahí es donde empezamos a recortar la
libertad de expresión volviendo al humor
o y digamos la mezcla con la religión
y la pregunta inicial no realmente hay
hay límites para eso sería coartar la
libertad de expresión de un humorista de
una de una persona
realmente realmente
incluso nos podemos reír de Dios nos
podemos reír de las mujeres de los trans
de las personas negras nos podemos reír
de todo la cuestión es
determinar que eso es eso es un
ejercicio de ficción pero la gente lo
confunde con la realidad y por eso matan
caricaturistas y matan periodistas
porque dicen la verdad
la verdad que que en algunos casos y
también como dice el dicho la verdad
duele no una una reflexión ya como para
para ir finalizando nuestra conversación
qué le puede decir a las personas que
nos están viendo sí que somos
evidentemente todos partes de la
sociedad como para para llegar a no
ofendernos Y también dejar que la gente
Pues hable y opine con con libertad
porque mucho muchas veces también sobre
todo en la prensa libre decimos hablamos
de libertad de expresión pero cuando uno
se expresa como uno quiere entonces
Viene otra persona a decir no puedes
decir esto esto y los otros también es
censura
a las personas que a las personas que
tienen el como ese como ese afán de
ofenderse por todo yo le digo que tienen
que primero que todo reírse porque
reírse es un mes es un remedio infalible
y yo creo que esa falta de autocrítica
El hecho el hecho de que una persona no
piense como yo
es algo que se me sale de de de mi
entorno se me sale mi control Entonces
no Por eso podría afectarme qué qué y
llevaría invitaría a la gente que más
bien debatiera a través de las razones
este tipo de este tipo de
confrontaciones pero el humor el una
vida se enamora es una vida es una vida
que le digo yo no ya triste
sí literalmente